what is up everybody it's animac here
for anime uproar and what if I told you
that the celestial dragons and the
entire system that revolves around them
is a complete farce the celestial
dragons also known as the world Nobles
are nothing but sacrificial pawns for
imusama and they only exist in order to
hide the truth about the real gods of
the red line these former Gods became
fallen angels as they were deliberately
replaced by the false gods of marijua
not only that but this is all directly
connected to Joy boy and the true nature
of the D Clan so let's get into it you
guys know the drill if you enjoy our one
piece content and you want to see more
in the future just leave a quick like
and comment it only takes a second but
it really helps me out a lot and of
course don't forget to subscribe to the
channel and hit that notification Bell
that's a huge help on YouTube and it's
completely free finally this video will
contain One Piece manga spoilers so
proceed with caution you have been
warned okay so here's the thing one
piece has great and nuanced World
building and most of the antagonists are
compelling characters with complex
motivations the world itself is also
complex it's not just black and white
for instance there are good Pirates who
just want freedom and there are
genuinely evil Pirates Who attack
innocent people and make them suffer at
the same time there are good people who
work for the Marines and the world
government like GARP Kobe and sengoku
and there are genuinely terrible people
on the side of the world government
people who are prepared to destroy
entire Islands full of innocent people
if they believe that such an action will
be advantageous for the world government
the destruction of Ohara comes to mind
here but there are many examples of the
world government doing terrible terrible
things on top of all that we also have
independent kingdoms that are just
trying to survive in this crazy world we
have the Warlords and the Young uncle
and all of this contributes to the
feeling that the world of one piece is
nuanced and multi-dimensional and in
that sense it's a lot like our own world
even though the world of one piece is
full of Fantastical creatures and
locations the culture and politics of
that world are well thought out and
realistic and yet having said all of
that there is one group of people that
seems to break this mold aside from very
few notable exceptions I am of course
talking about the celestial dragons who
are easily the least complex characters
in the entire story I mean they suffer
from a massive God complex and they
consider everyone who is not a world
Noble to be inherently inferior to them
because of this they treat other people
like objects they literally enslave and
abuse whomever they want and laws simply
do not apply to them they can seemingly
do whatever they want whenever they want
and the only person who is allowed to
defy the will of a Celestial Dragon is
another Celestial Dragon herding even a
single Celestial Dragon is so dangerous
that it could lead to the destruction of
an entire Kingdom and so the world
Nobles can get away with pretty much
anything they are easily the least
likable characters in the entire story
as exemplified by Saint Charles the
owner of the most punchable face in the
history of anime the celestial dragons
are so obsessed with the idea that they
are superior to everyone else that they
are often seen wearing outfits that look
like spacesuits and which have an oxygen
tank attached to a glass case that
covers their face they apparently wear
these ridiculous suits because they
don't want to breathe the same air as
lowly commoners the celestial dragons
live on top of the red line in a place
known as the domain of the Gods which is
a sort of holy land that they of course
consider to be superior to all other
locations in the world although some
Celestial dragons such as certain
members of the Don Quixote family have
defied conventions by treating those who
are not World Nobles as actual human
beings worthy of respect this seems to
be a rare exception in the world of the
celestial dragons and all of this really
begs the question why are these
characters so one-dimensional and so
utterly unlikable more importantly why
would the shadow ruler of the world
government prop up these detestable
clowns in ridiculous spacesuits as the
public faces of the world government's
ruling Elite I think we can safely
assume that imusama and the gorosei are
intelligent individuals and capable
rulers so why do they tolerate the
behavior of the celestial dragons surely
they know that the arrogance and cruelty
of the celestial dragons is only
breeding animosity towards the world
government and they have to know that
the ruthless behavior of the world
Nobles creates instability by increasing
the likelihood of rebellion and
resistance from people who are being so
blatantly oppressed and don't even give
me started on those silly space suits at
first many people theorized that the
spacesuits were clues about the true
origins of the celestial dragons
essentially the theory was that they
were from outer space and more
specifically from the Moon we already
know that an advanced civilization once
lived on the moon and their descendants
are the winged people from the various
Sky Islands but the celestial dragons
don't have wings and there's another big
problem here from everything we know
about the world of One Piece you don't
need a spacesuit in order to breathe in
space you can go into space and to the
Moon while just breathing normal air
this may sound crazy at first but we
have to remember that before modern
science actually confirmed that there
was no oxygen in outer space most people
believed that you could in fact breathe
in space many fictional stories that
featured the moon as a setting including
myths fantasies and early science
fiction stories portrayed the moon as
having perfectly breathable oxygen the
world of one p seems to take this false
belief about our own Moon and turns it
into a reality with the moon in one
piece and Al is able to go up to the
moon and hang out there without any sort
of spacesuit a bunch of different space
pirates who seem to be of various races
and species don't use a spacesuit either
and when we see those ancient drawings
on the moon the ones that depict members
of the advanced civilization that used
to reside there those people are not
depicted with any sort of space suit
either so based on the information that
we have so far we have to assume that in
the world of One Piece you don't
actually need a spacesuit to go into
space and that just makes the fact that
Celestial dragons wear what look like
spacesuits even more strange in our
world the suits might indicate that they
came from space or that they are trying
to reference space in some way but in
their world that wouldn't make sense the
only practical purpose of the suits
seems to be avoiding breathing the same
air as commoners and there doesn't
appear to be any deeper meaning behind
it so the only role of these suits is to
make the celestial dragons look as
ridiculous as possible while also
emphasizing the fact that they are cruel
elitists with a superiority complex and
that they treat everyone else like
lesser life forms once again setting up
these people as the public face of the
ruling Elite within the world government
is just the worst possible PR move and
it honestly baffles me that individuals
who are otherwise clearly intelligent
than machiavellians such as imusama
decided to set up a system that is just
inviting people to rebel against it I
mean how much smarter would it be to
just make the celestial dragons appear
benevolent and generous in public
imagine if they brought gifts for the
poor in every Kingdom they visited
imagine if they at least pretended to be
kind and compassionate towards the
people that they ruled over imagine if
they demonstrated even basic competence
when it comes to statesmanship if they
behaved in this way even if it was all
just an act it would make it much easier
to keep the people obedient even if the
actual political system within the world
government didn't change at all just
making these simple surface level public
relations changes to the way that the
celestial dragons are perceived would go
a long way to perpetuating the world
government system and discouraging
people from joining revolutionary
movements or sympathizing with pirates
and yet imusama and the gorosei have
chosen to preside over a system that is
almost designed to make everyone hate
the celestial dragons and speaking of
the gorosei notice how despite also
being Celestial dragons they don't wear
ridiculous spacesuits they don't have
cringy hair buns and they don't act
pompous and obnoxious towards those who
are not World Nobles for example they
are perfectly willing to meet with
Shanks in private and when they do meet
with them they don't seem worried about
breathing the same air as him or having
him bow before them the goros say
clearly know what Smart statesmanship
looks like they know how to leaders and
they make those spacesuit wearing World
Nobles look absolutely goofy by
comparison and I think that this is the
key point the vast majority of the
celestial dragons are goofy
one-dimensional villains with extremely
punchable faces because that is exactly
what they were always supposed to be
they are mere puppets of imusama and the
gorosei and they are simply playing the
role that the true ruler of the world
government had assigned to them without
them even realizing it in other words
aside from the gorosei the celestial
dragons are nothing but pawns who are
about to be sacrificed by imusama in
order to preserve his or her power I
believe that imusama is well aware that
big changes to the structure of the
world are on the horizon the return of
Joy boy has long been foretold the
Golden Age of the Pirates has been
shaking things up for over two decades
the Revolutionary Army is on the rise
and so on the many enemies of the world
government are amassing and they are
getting stronger Luffy has awakened the
Nika fruit and is stronger than ever
Blackbeard is also getting more and more
dangerous the revolutionaries are making
serious inroads and all of them see the
celestial dragons as their enemy all of
them want to put an end to the corrupt
system that places the world Nobles at
the top and everyone else below them
except we know that the world Nobles are
not really at the top everyone just
thinks that they are the empty Throne is
not really empty although it's occupant
imusama has gone out of his or her way
to keep his or her existence a secret so
what is imusama really up to many fans
have speculated that imusama has
actually been alive for a very long time
perhaps even since the void Century if
this is true then imusama knows how the
world Works imusama knows that military
con conflicts and drastic political
changes are inevitable and that they
happen in Cycles over the course of
decades and centuries when you push
people far enough they will inevitably
fight back and this will lead to the
collapse of one political regime and the
rise of another so what if imusama has
been preparing for this very thing what
if the celestial dragons are supposed to
be one-dimensional and obnoxious
villains because they were always
intended to be sacrificed and replaced
with a different ruling Elite while the
actual ruler behind the scenes Remains
the Same a lot of us have wondered why
imusama had four photos in his or her
possession photos which show the Luffy
Blackbeard shirahoshi and Vivi the other
three photos were all damaged in some
way either ripped or stabbed but vivi's
photo remained intact my personal pet
theory about this was that the four
photos may be related to the ancient
weapons but there is another possibility
imusama could be looking for a new
public face of the World Government
after the current public face the
celestial dragons are inevitably
overthrown what if these four photos
represent four rising stars who have the
potential to replace the celestial
dragons as the new rulers of the world
government although they would of course
be ruling in name only because the real
ruler is imusama three of the photos are
damaged because imusama ultimately
decided that they wouldn't be a good fit
they were ruled out Luffy and Blackbeard
are definitely Rising quickly both in
terms of their power and their notoriety
but they are also far too dangerous and
unpredictable shirahoshi is nowhere near
as dangerous and unpredictable as the
other two but discrimination against the
fish man is rampant on the surface world
so trying to convince everyone to follow
a mermaid as their next ruler would be a
very hard sell as the incident between
shirahoshi and Charles at the reverie
demonstrates so Vivi might actually be
imusama's pick for the next public face
of the World Government after the
celestial dragons are overthrown I mean
just think about it all of these
powerful forces have aligned themselves
against the world government and it's
clear that a major Showdown is coming
what better way for imusama to remain in
power than to trick the enemies of the
world government into thinking that they
won everyone hates the celestial dragons
so imusama can just sacrifice them in
order to make everyone think that they
got what they wanted the tyranny of the
celestial dragons is over and a new
ruler has taken their place this new
ruler is Young Brave and charismatic and
she is a member of the nefertari royal
family one of the founding families of
the world government so she is royalty
but she is not a world Noble from
marijua which makes the people think
that she will bring about real change
change and yet the one who really wields
all the power behind the scenes would be
the same as before the one who sits on
the empty Throne imusama if imusama
really had all of this planned out it
would be some of the most Machiavellian
stuff I've ever seen in the anime not
only is imusama controlling one ruling
regime from behind the scenes but he or
she is already making preparations to
control the next regime once this one is
overthrown imusama will simply replace
one puppet regime with another and
everyone will be happy because they will
think that actual change has occurred as
a result of all their hard work and
sacrifice in reality only the facade
will have been changed and the core
structure will remain the same and not
only is this possible but something
similar may already have occurred in the
past we now know that before marijua
even existed the red line was inhabited
by a race of god-like creatures known as
the lunarians just like the celestial
dragons they were not actual Gods but
they were a very powerful race with
Incredible abilities which is why they
were treated like Gods by others they
had large black wings which allowed them
to fly they had the ability to generate
and manipulate fire and they had
superhuman physical resilience and yet
this race of overpowered people is now
practically extinct with King being the
only known Survivor it is quite likely
that the lunarians were defeated during
the void century and that their place as
Gods who live Atop The Red Line was
usurped by the celestial dragons the
lunarians were the original Celestial
dragons the original gods of the red
line and the current Celestial dragons
are just Pretenders to the throne the
current Celestial dragons were put into
Power by imusama in order to maintain
stability in the world by creating a new
system that was somewhat similar to the
old one with an elite group of so-called
Divine beings rule ruling over the world
from Atop The Red Line but the new
system concentrated all the real power
in imusama and the celestial dragons
themselves are just puppets we know that
even today at least 800 or 900 years
after the fall of the lunarians the
world government still hunts them down
and offers cash rewards for any
information that could lead to capturing
a lunarian which is likely one of the
reasons why the lunarians are
practically extinct because of this I
believe it's possible that imusama
already orchestrated one massive regime
change in the past back when the
lunarians were overthrown and replaced
by the celestial dragons and imusama
could be planning to do something
similar in the future once the time is
right in fact it is possible that the
original Joy boy himself was a lunarian
and that the capital of the ancient
kingdom was actually up top the red line
it might have even been located where
marijua is now and marijua was only
Built there there in order to cover up
the ruins of the ancient Kingdom we know
that the world government has been
actively hunting the lunarians for
centuries which suggests that they
clearly see the lunarians as a massive
threat and one other thing that they've
been hunting for centuries is the Nika
devil fruit if the original Joy boy was
a lunarian who also possessed the Nika
devil fruit this would explain why he
was such a huge threat to the world
government he would have been incredibly
overpowered and this could be why the
world government is so obsessed with
hunting down both the lunarians and
Anika devil fruit they might have
believed that Joy boy would one day
return as a lunarian so along with
hunting the Nika devil fruit they also
decided to hunt every lunarian just to
cover all their bases essentially by
trying to locate every lunarian and the
Nika devil fruit at the same time they
were actively trying to prevent the
prophesized return of Joy boy but now
that Joy boy has returned turned in the
form of Luffy another Machiavellian
regime change may be in order courtesy
of imusama the rulers of the world who
live Atop The Red Line may be replaced
yet again but the true power behind the
scenes will remain in the hands of the
same person this being a Shonen we can
assume that Luffy and the Gang will find
a way to foil this plan at the end and
before I end this video I do want to
address a really interesting comment I
got on my video about the void Century a
commenter named Crest suggested that the
d-clan may actually be descendants of
the real dragons the ones who ruled Atop
The Red Line before they were replaced
by the current regime so the D might
actually stand for Dragon the true
dragon and this is why the d-clan are
natural enemies of the so-called gods in
marijua members of the d-clan are the
natural enemies of the celestial dragons
because they are the rightful rulers of
the world and the Celestial Dragon are
just usurpers this is definitely a
fascinating idea although we don't yet
have a direct connection between the
d-clan and the lunarians the members of
the d-clan certainly don't have the
genetic features that are associated
with lunarians so if the lunarians
really were the original Celestial
dragons then there has to be some
explanation for why the d-clan would
inherit this title despite not being
descended from lunarians and if this
were the case and if the D really did
stand for Dragon then Luffy's dad's name
would be monkey dragon dragon which is
kind of weird but hey who knows either
way I really like this idea of imusama
using the obnoxious Goofy and extremely
punchable World Nobles as nothing more
than Expendable puppets in a grand
master plan and I also like the notion
that the d-clan may be the only ones who
are capable of exposing the real truth
about imusama we do still need a
connection between the ancient Kingdom
the lunarians and the a d-clan but with
the way that the manga is going that
connection could be revealed at any
moment and of course if it is one they
confirm that the original Joy boy was a
lunarian and that the capital of the
ancient kingdom was located on top of
the red line then that will put us very
close to finally deciphering all of the
Mysteries in one piece definitely let me
know what you guys think was Joy Boy the
original Joy boy actually a lunarian and
are the celestial dragons just usurping
the position of the true Celestial
dragons the lunarians is imusama
planning to sacrifice the world Nobles
as part of a grand plan to remain in
power while making everyone think that
the old regime has been overthrown and
is imusama planning on using Vivi as the
new face of the world government don't
forget to leave your thoughts down in
the comments below if you guys enjoyed
this video and you want to see more
one-piece content right here on the
channel leave a quick like and comment
it only takes a second but it really
helps with that YouTube algorithm and of
course subscribing and hitting that
notification Bell is a completely free
but very real way of directly supporting
the channel you can also hit me up on
Twitter and Instagram at anime uproar as
always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see ya
Space Cowboys